I am the diligent researcher at the
squid research lab who has spent day and
night researching the mysterious squid
creatures that can take on human form
I've been researching a new variety of
squid that was discovered recently and
today I'm here to announce the fruits of
my labor it has been about two years
since I first discovered the squid and
it seems there have been many changes to
the squid world in that time turf war is
therefore on for team-based battles
where the two teams compete to spray the
ground with ink and covered most turf
this remains a popular sport but it
appears the battle stages have changed
and the fashions and weapons used have
also evolved here you see the latest
piece of technology this weapon set is
called the splat Dooley's not only do
these dual wielded weapons let you shoot
ink from each hand they also have
nozzles that can propel you at a high
rate of speed to outmaneuver your
opponents it is a fearsome weapon in the
hands of one who has mastered it and it
appears this special weapons which can
be activated after spraying enough
ground with ink are all brand new surely
with the introduction of new weapons all
new special weapons and new battle
stages we will see the emergence of new
battle strategies I expect our research
will continue to keep us busy allow me
to report briefly uncontrolled of course
you can use the joy Kong controllers but
you can also play using the pro
controller you can play on the TV screen
and you can also play in handheld mode
and of course in either mode you can use
gyro controls to aim your ink you press
the X button to view the map
and to do a super jump you press the
button assigned to a teammate to
instantly jump there of course you can
battle against friends and people you
don't know over the Internet and you can
also bring your games and Nintendo
switch systems together to
out of friends face-to-face that is all
from the squid research lab oh I almost
forgot something very important what do
too is planned for long this summer and
again this time there will be stage and
weapon updates after launch and there
are also plans to hold ongoing in-game
events I am very excited to once again
enjoy those exciting times with everyone
all around the world
splatoon - still has many elements that
we have yet to uncover the squid
research lab will continue to share new
details as we discover them thank you
for your time today